the homeland security secretary is in
South Texas telling people he needs a
bigger budget to manage Asylum Seekers
and migrants at the southern border
crossings are likely to jump when a
pandemic error policy expires next week
Omar villafranca is at the border where
officials are struggling with those who
are already there
it's a familiar scene in The Border Town
of El Paso Texas
people desperately escaping violence and
poverty facing uncertainty waiting in
groups crowding sidewalks hoping for a
chance for a new home with nothing but
the clothes on their backs and their
children at their side
this mother or two crossed the border
with her one and three-year-old no
family in the U.S only friends and she's
hoping to get to Ohio where she plans to
find any job she can to support her two
girls
shelters like the Sacred Heart receive a
majority of their funding from private
donations with little government
assistance Charities are stepping in to
provide Basics like food and blankets at
night the blankets are used for warmth
but during the day they're used to block
the west Texas Sun like this blanket
right here which is from the American
Red Cross many of the migrants have been
on the streets for days but some say
it's better than the life they left
behind
title 42 the pandemic era policy that
allows the government to expel migrants
to prevent the spread of coven will
expire next week Customs and Border
Patrol officials say when that happens
there could be as many as ten thousand
border crossings each day nearly
doubling the daily average in March this
is really not an El Paso issue it's a
international migration issue father
Rafael Garcia runs the Sacred Heart
shelter he says his staff can only do so
much for the nearly 1400 migrants who
cross into El Paso every day we're
focusing on women and children mainly
the need is overwhelming Garcia fears
the scene from six months ago is already
repeating itself and it'll only get
worse once title 42 expires El Paso
County Judge Ricardo Samaniego says the
federal help is in enough and the
governor doesn't coordinate are you
getting any help from the state that's
the missing component if we don't do
this properly it's going to impact the
entire nation for CBS mornings Omar via
Franca in El Paso Texas